secondo me non piace ma piacerà
tantissimo piacere perché per per te no
piacere anche per te ancora con 67
coccio
ciao ragazzi benvenuti in questo nuovo
attesissimo video perché c'è lo
aspettavate più del natale insomma il
primo video di marina insieme a la più
famosa madre del web
magic nadia ecco a voi mia mamma detto
nadia dic name di in stack nostra volete
seguire chiocciola kg to die neue
trattino tantino basso avevo annunciato
questo video quindi mi avete pagato
tutte varie domande da fare a mia mamma
quindi è un video ask mi conosceva
veramente mia mamma non solo ovviamente
subito
partiamo colori preferiti di marina rosa
e nero e oro oro nero
risposta esatta segata domanda materie
preferite quando andava a scuola in
materia che invece odiavo odiava il
disegno e la matematica che ti piacevano
italiano e lingue straniere come siria
come marina fin da piccolo molto
esagitata molto esagerata
espressiva cerchiamo di mantenerci
affettuose tenera creativa abbiamo
talvolta talvolta birichina salvatevi
ricky ma andiamo avanti
domanda numero non mi ricordo che sia
nel vestire marina qui questi di serie
tv ed è uno stile diciamo non classico
piuttosto esagerato un po fuori le righe
una parola che è ancora cosa non poco
molto poco
esse sono sobri è proprio è uno dei tuoi
aggettivi preferiti la sobrietà comelico
prima di prima di tutto
allora c'era un jeans che si era
strappato proprio sotto la chiappa a me
piaceva tantissimo trovo molto
underground poi che è successo alla mia
insaputa è andata a farlo ricucire
ricucire c'è poco che apprendo
indovinate un po cosa è successo dopo la
riaperto in cosa ti batte marina e in
cosa invece dibattito maria viva ha
tempi biblici cosa ti ho appena fatto
bere medio carta cosa che io non sono
mai riuscite a farne a mano si trucca se
magro prova anche dobbiamo dire che tua
mamma è sempre stata un tipo anche la
ragazza acqua e sapone bene infatti non
riesco a capire la quito abbia preso
perché le roi migliorare sempre
sì sì sì tu hai dei talenti che io non
mi spiego quale gamma dell'equilibrio
marina basco allora io mi ricordo come
se fosse ora che per un regalo di
compleanno
tu mi hai detto sia in un ricalco blando
i suoi trovava per quel ricomprando io
voglio poter vedere tv melo economy non
so ora tu mi ha detto se finisci tutti i
compiti delle vacanze si accenda lavori
catto questo io avrei un pochino dove
facciamo tutti avevo un pochino a freno
però di massima ci lasciamo libera nella
tua creatività
come era marina adolescente come si
comportava era un po male
l'adolescenza è stato un periodo un po
più duro e forse qualche bugia mela
anche detta a tutte le 15mila raccontava
dopo e io invece mi sa bene quali erano
le bugie che andavo a ballare 9000 micam
andava a ballare sentiero montare in
queste cosette consigliera lina di turno
anche aveva la mamma che faceva fare
tutte quindi tutta davano magicamente
tutto il weekend se nella dominata
questa amica e quindi era venerdì sabato
c'è stato un calo
sì sì un po coloca cross nei mitici su
medico ricordiamo ragazzi divertitevi
nei meeting di alto preferito di a maria
chiara va da sé che quello è una cosa
che fa sempre
insomma una cosa strana ha fatto la cura
e il cusi una lasagna quella della nonna
che io non sono
ecco mi ha mai cucinato tanto brava la
battuta a gamba tesa in cucina e del mio
più grande orgoglio veramente sono
contenta di teli quello che fai in tutti
i tuoi talenti perché tu sei arrivata
superarono in cucina per me è il massimo
come ti immaginavi mari alla grande
sapevo che aveva questo sogno che le
piaceva cantare io voglio sempre
appoggiata e speravo che
il giorno diventata portante cioè che
avrebbe trovato la sua strada
sono diventata un'altra nota un'altra
roba
però sapevo che però sembra veramente
importanti saresti arrivata perché sei
sempre stata cioè quello è stato il tuo
sogno sia stata determinata
nonostante diciamo qualche parere
negativo del papa e tu hai voluto
seguire la tua strada a noi
e qui sei arrivata veramente in questo
non sai da ammirare che mamma pensi di
essere una mamma anomala
prendiamo sempre innanzitutto non solo
l'attività mamma bravissima in cucina
o devia ma in altre doti altri interessi
e altre doti comunque al 6 una fotografa
mi piace l'arte la sembrava invece la
rosa
adoro la lirica diciamo tanti interessi
così artistici e culturali
tanti anche se tanto però forse non sono
una perfetta donna di casa se marina
fosse una principessa disney che
principessa sarebbe che poi qual è il
mio preferito di marina da tutti però
per esempio quello che mai veramente
stupita e è quello in cui fai la mamma
perché mi sono rivista è stata
incredibile e stato uno shock
come si chiama vi aspetta con la
parrucca come ci vedono le nostre mamme
e avevo i capelli corti e sembravo io
quando tu sei nata per cui io ti seguo
essermi un abito le perle questa codice
della strada come siamo realmente giusto
metà l'altro il mio video che ha fatto
più visualizzazione fatto due io
lascerei mai view verona sta veramente
sorpresa di mi sono prevista e eroina ma
anche messo tuo vestito pro collana la
parrucca di come i capelli e quindi ero
nadia da giovane invece c'è un altro
video che piaciuto molto che si chiama
tipologie di mamme si
ecco tu in questo video poi le mamme
pensili quale mamma bensì di essere
quella di proverbi sicuro la dei
probabili quali sempre più proverbi noi
la social ultimamente instagram baseball
ansiosa
alla sorella lontano sia per social beh
ma è per forza di cose insomma tu sei
entrata in questo mondo del web
io per starti vicino e per conoscere
questo mondo hanno variato è giusto così
allora un'ultima domanda in quale
programma della televisione italiana mi
vedresti tu potresti ripresentare niente
come showgirl presentatrice di un
programma importante perché ha la
capacità di far cosa adone attimo ad
ogni piccola sensazione sto vivendo con
te
i miei primi momenti da quando io l'ho
conosciuto per te e per me è più pace
non c'è concludiamo questo video con un
pensiero e una lingua a te molto cara ai
to gray lo spagnolo
hasta la victoria siempre e questo è il
tuo motto nella vita siccome siamo un po
diverso ci vogliamo tantissimo è boom
allora mi sa che domande che abbia fatto
abbastanza ma ci sarà sicuramente la
seconda parte perché
e se vi è piaciuto il video ha come al
solito come dico io se mi è piaciuto
video batte il like mettete il sale mi
lanciano 97 mettete un like commentate
fateci sapere se vi piace questa nuovo
questo nuovo formato video con nadia
magic nadia ovvero mia madre e
iscrivetevi al canale se non avete
ancora fatto
seguite mamma su instagram che dice se
vi piacciono le mie fusano a lei in
oriente dice che la gente la segue
soltanto perché mi ama le fece lei una
ottima fotografa delle bellissime foto e
soprattutto è molto brava a scrivere io
sto pressando per scrivere un libro che
sicuramente sarà un successone
editoriale fatto prova mi faccio provate
ciao ragazzi alla prossima
io adoro